what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel ring
that notification Bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
like the video on your way in guys
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these live
streams also get your women sh have vote
t-shirt today you know the link to that
is in the description okay so um my
producers found me a video uh labeled
what I learned from my ho face so
hopefully this is a woman that it's
reflecting on a whole phas and saying
that was a horrible thing to do terrible
I shouldn't have did it and now I have
consequences let's pull it up if you
think that you need a ho phas if you
think that you need to participate in
hookup culture at least as a woman
chances are you just need a really good
vibrator and a really good therapist a
lot of people say well I'm going to have
a ho face perfectly fine I've done it
couple of times and here's what I've
learned what I learned in voting School
is blankety
blanky hey y'all it's me juwel if it's
your first time here what's up you know
what's interesting all right modern
women a lot of times we get it but we're
so close you know what I mean King like
you hear her like you might need a
therapist and a vibrator okay you were
really close you were really close a
husband you see it's like it's like
you're almost almost there you like
tonight I wanted to talk about hookup
culture how it pertains to either
heterosexual women or heter seexual
presenting women I say that because I
know B oh dear women are not
heterosexual but a lot of times they end
up in heterosexual presenting
relationships I saw a Tik Tok I don't
remember the girl's username or anything
unfortunately but it said that
cisgendered heterosexual women are
really bad at hookup culture and at
first I was like what no what do what do
you mean that's that's a cisgender what
does cisgender mean is that straight so
like men okay freaking ridiculous and
I've heard a lot of discourse around
this topic a lot of people saying that
hookup culture is not the feminist Flex
that we think it is and how it's been
like portrayed in the media especially
in pop music and R&B music within the
past couple and like TV How I Met Your
Mother Sex in the City of years so I
will admit I've had a couple of ho
phases if you know me in real life and
you're watching this video no you don't
so I've had a couple of ho phases
empowered by the whole idea of I own my
body I do what I want with it I don't
have to the Virgin Mary and you know my
see my rules so pretty much then I got
to thinking what exactly is hookup
culture and how does this relate to a
whole phase it's all going to come
around full circle in a second hookup
culture is really just a phenomenon that
glorifies sex typically glorifies I
don't want to say meaningless sex but
yeah like kind of meaningless sex like
you're not building deep relationships
with these people most of the time the
objective is physical satisfaction right
and so why I agree with the idea that
cisgendered heterosexual women when I
say women I'm going to mean cisgendered
heterosexual wom while I'm talking in
this context in this video cuz I don't
want to have to keep saying cisgendered
heterosexual women so that's just what I
mean so the objective is pretty much
physical gratification there's supposed
to be no emotions involved if you have a
sneaky link you know it's it's purely
physical it's just for sex all right I I
know I know what a ho come on I it's
self why do we need the explanation you
know like we know no emotions because
jinz is all about ignoring our romantic
feelings because we don't need nobody
else cuz people are disappointments
right a lot of people say well I'm going
to have a ho phas perfectly fine I've
done it a couple of times and here's
what I've learned what I learned in
voting school is blankety blankety BL I
agree hookup culture it's not made to
benefit women it's not made to empower
women and it will never be to benefit
nor Empower women if anything it's I
don't even know what the word is for it
it doesn't benefit us and there's a a
lot more risk involved for women than
there are for men so women are taking on
a lot more risk and we're getting a lot
less in return and you're probably
thinking juwel what do you mean hook
up I don't know men have the risk of
getting like me to it's like a both up
but okay yeah it's basically just giving
away your value for free culture is so
great for women to learn their bodies
and explore no I mean I don't know where
this idea came from that you need to
have a whole phase I literally don't I I
don't understand how women bought this
like we used to get like a lifetime
marriage and exchange for sex now but
you already know we'll always leave The
Peasant for the king it's just kind of
how we are blah blah blah which all that
may be true for some people I don't
think it's true for a majority of people
here's what I've learned in notice if
you want to argue don't argue with your
mama don't argue with me because these
are my opinions and when things are
facts I will tell you that they are
facts so the benefit for women I could
only I could only come up with two
benefits for women that come from hookup
culture and that come from having a
whole face again from my literal own
experience the only two benefits I could
think of were validation because whether
you want to admit it or not sex is some
form of validation especially for women
the only other one I could think of was
sexual satisfaction So Physical
satisfaction but that comes with a
caveat because we know a majority of
women do not have orgasms when they're
having sex with men so well it's not
with men it's with men that don't care
about you to be honest that's it's so
funny cuz these feminists will come out
and just say like oh the men are so bad
in bed like women haven't experienced
all this like yeah and it's like well I
mean if you're sleeping with dudes that
don't care about you that's probably
what's going to happen and it's so funny
cuz you see the feminists like kind of
coming around and being like wait this
actually isn't good it's actually bad
and then they're like yeah yeah okay let
me just ultimately what's the main
benefit for for hookup culture for women
it's going to be validation because half
the time sexual SL physical satisfaction
is not we're going to get those are the
two benefits that I could think of for
women and the only other argument that I
hear that's a benefit for women is that
if you have like a whole phase and you
have like all of these like sexual
experience and sexual partners you get
to learn what you do and don't like
pretty much through trial and error and
I I heavily disagree with that one
because of the cons that's associated
with hookup culture for women casual sex
for women and two because ultimately I
feel like you don't have to have
multiple random sexual partners to
figure out what you do and don't like in
bed for one you can figure that out by
yourself I wanted to say that I do think
it's important to learn your body and
learn what you do like and don't like
sexually but you don't need to have a
lot of sexual partners to figure that
out like you can have one sexual partner
who cares enough to help you figure that
out with you you we're so close you see
how she's almost coming to the
conclusion of a husband we get so close
but it's like no no no tomato need to
have like five different partners to
figure that out just want to throw that
in there like you're going to need to
learn what you like sexually and you're
going to want to do that with someone
else but it doesn't have to be a whole
bunch of uh like random people who don't
care about you in my opinion if you
think that you need a ho phas if you
think that you need to participate in
hookup hure at least as a woman I'll at
least I'll give it to her she's being
honest we do appreciate honesty here but
it's it's unfortunate because a lot of
older women give terrible advice to
younger women and they just say oh do
what you want with your
body and then yeah and this is the
result it's like women that regret it
chances are you just need a really good
vibrator and a really good therapist so
close so close so I mean all right well
we'll take it that's just how I feel I
think that you can figure out what you
like sexually with and by yourself
without having to expose yourself to all
the cons that I'm going to get into now
so again those are the two really like
one and a half benefits of hookup
culture that I could think of the risks
Associated and I have this written down
first risk is that STDs are going to be
higher in women women are more likely to
contract STDs than men are I did not
know that until a friend informed me and
I was like I'm sorry what women and men
don't contract STDs at the same rate and
she said no my friend so there's that
two our all favorite is pregnancy
because it takes yeah and it's it's like
one and it's either I can't I forget
which is which but it's like one in
three women have I had an ND one in four
to detangle But ultimately the burden is
going to fall on one of the two parties
and it's going to be the one with the
uterus and especially for black women in
America what are we like four times more
likely to die during child birth than
women and offer what a crusty man that
you met on Tinder all right that's
that's uncalled for that's uncalled for
I mean you're the Crusty woman he met on
Tinder [__] it's like it takes two to
tango no thank you next sexual
frustration is something that a lot of
women report when having sex with male
partners because for the five billion
time most women do not get sexually
satisfied from men that don't care about
you because that that's the key here
that is the key you know what's funny
virgins that get married uh do report
sexual satisfaction in their marriage so
maybe it's just kind of you're too
broken by the time you get married
they're having sex especially with
hookup culture because I feel like when
you're in a committed relationship with
someone at least how it should be that
person should be dedicated and caring
enough to make sure that you're
satisfied sexually right when you're a
hookup culture a lot of people I was
going to say a lot of men but really A
lot of people are very selfish so
they're not going to take the time to
see that don't that don't care if
learn your body they don't have the time
to learn your body because it's a one
anddone quick McDonald's fast food type
of exchange I I feel like with hookup
culture so so you can possibly get
pregnant you can possibly get an STD
more likely than men and you're possibly
going to be sexually flustrated and
again even with contraceptives even with
protection these things yeah and
contraceptives mess you up too you know
I I I tell the story I have a nanny that
was literally like my favorite Nanny
ever like I I remember like crying for
weeks when she left I was so sad and um
literally she ended up not having kids
because um and she would have been such
a great mother and I know cuz like you
know she was you know sort of like
partially that figure for me for a bit
and she um yeah she didn't have kids BEC
and she married young too it was so sad
because she got that like shot there's
some shot they were giving out to
prevent STDs or whatever back in the day
I guess and she got it and now she can't
have kids and she's just turned like 40
recently so it's really sad all still
factors that are possible and then my
last one which I have experienced before
is like emotional destruction how many
times have you had sex with a man and
afterwards you just feel kind of like
used and like gross but sex is a very
emotional thing for women let's add up
the pros and cons shall we so Pros we
have two more like one and A2 cons we
have four two of them possibly
lifethreatening one of them only women
can incur the burden of I.E pregnancy so
that's why I say that hookup culture is
not I don't think I agree I don't think
it's feminist Flex that a lot of people
think that it is because of all of the
inherent risk that women are taking on
that men are not taking on I don't think
it's the feminist Flex we think it is
because of all of the mental destruction
that it can have on a woman and it's
really hard growing up in this Society
like I totally get it where you feel
like you should have a ho age you should
have a hookup culture you should be you
know pimping these [__] out or
whatever but I don't pimp it what does
that mean to pimp a guy out you know
what that means basically sleeping
around but then wouldn't you be the one
getting pimped how do you pimp out up I
think a lot of us are honest enough with
ourselves to say that that's not what we
want and I'm not even bashing having a
whole face I'm not bashing hookup
culture because like I've said I've been
a part of it um I just recently got out
of an expedition I had no business
taking but I do what I want but I got a
good therapist now so cardi said you
know if [__] dope I'm the dope dealer
and if py good shouldn't have to
maintain a brok so also actually this is
a tangent I don't even have this written
down this wasn't even planned the fact
that the idea of us using v as a sense
of currency with men also is very
strange to me and not even in the sense
of sex working if you do sex work it's
fine like you know like that's that's
your profession but in the sense of like
I going to use my vaginal powers to get
things from men like money and status or
whatever but at the same time you know
I'm like if men are feeding into this
and if the one superpower women have is
the vagine then I totally get it maybe
we should be using it to our advantage
but I I don't know I don't know the
whole thing's very weird beauty is the
most uh prized commodity really I'll
tell you why there's guys that have made
hundreds of billions billions of dollars
and all a woman had to do was have sex
with him to get it like what's more
valuable than
that yeah um it's so funny watching
these feminists like kind of their world
view like unravel world they're like you
know maybe being a isn't good but and
and it's so funny cuz you could see her
like turning and her realizing what's
true but still kind of being like but if
you guys want to do it that's fine no
this is why we need to reinstate social
shame and it's all by a case by casee
basis but anyway I think of a lot of
song lyrics that have to do with vagine
and hookup culture and pop in that P
because also like Megan said talk your
[__] bite your lip ask for a car while
you ride that so maybe that's why a lot
of women that's maybe that's why a lot
of see see this is her admitting it we
are so influenced by the media and the
culture just because this is just how we
are as chicks you know I mean I I I'm
not this is why it's so important that
we have a guy in our lives you know
whether it be a father husband brother
like we need male guidance because women
are just easily influenced it's just you
know female you feel like hooking up
with men is this feminist Flex because
we're using our innate superpower which
is the vag to get money to get cars to
get our bills paid to get status but
again I first of all most men is broke
most of us are not asking for car most
women are broke too but I mean most
people are I mean most people just have
normal income while we ride that because
he's driving his mama's car most of them
are broke so we're incurring all these
risk again for broke men okay they get
so close how old does she look like 22
23 what do you think how much money is
does anyone have at 24 I was broke at 24
I mean you know I I you know YouTube you
know but like this is this is not
reality you know it's like what what do
you expect but now now it's like she's
looking down on men because they're
broke when it's like she's so close so
close to the sleep don't me that cuz
that that don't sound like a good time
maybe maybe I'm the problem maybe I'm
just not having a ho face with the right
richond I don't know what's going on and
I even did a poll on my Instagram and I
said do you think that hookup culture
has any benefit for women it was pretty
split But ultimately I believe the
results came out to be no funnily enough
men had the audacity to well and you see
it I mean why do you think Taylor Swift
has a million songs talking about how
much it sucks you know it's it's a lie
that's been sold to women and it really
doesn't benefit men either because we
just all sleep with the same guys so
it's like it's like 10% of guys screwing
all the chicks and then the rest of men
are just sexless vote as if I was
talking to them and funnily enough a lot
of men said no a lot of men on my
Instagram voted no that hookup culture
doesn't have any benefit for women which
I think is really funny because like
they know that this isn't benefiting us
but they're still going to partake in it
because
it's I I've I've pointed this out women
will find the first person to blame who
does she blame the men and it's so funny
because they don't open your legs like
what do you gosh this so benefit them
like think about it man they're going to
nut like 9.5 times out of 10 like
they're going to get theirs right like
they're going to obviously and that has
no benefit to the women like [__] off
what's that have to do with them so I
found that really interesting like I
think like they know what they know what
they be doing like they're not as dense
as they may seem this is not a video
bashing men but I mean it kind of sounds
like it a bit like if the shoe fits go
off King she's so dumb because literally
she said the men told her that it
doesn't benefit women but they still
partake in it obviously but then they
not lying to you they telling you the
truth but you choose not to listen so
who's the stupid one
here well it's like I mean we know it
doesn't benefit us cuz the first thing
we do when we're mad is called a chick a
[__] you know what I mean it's like
whatever that's not really my fault now
is it but that's really it for today's
video I just want to have a chitchat and
do a face mask and see how y'all do yeah
this just sounds super super smart this
is the thing like men will let us talk
like this and they just don't say
anything when we sound like idiots uh
chica um you know it's funny feminist
really almost come to the conclusion
that I make which is patriarchy is the
best but they don't they don't quite get
there and it's so funny cuz everything
that she's saying all the solutions the
the STDs the lack of sexual satisfaction
Etc really would be solved with a
husband but we don't want to have that
conversation do we anyways guys let me
know what you think in the comments like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time